role-based user authorization can give
you fine-grained control over which
actions a user can perform in your app
many apps use this strategy such as
Stack Overflow and reddit to control the
types of data that can be modified by
users in this episode we're going to
implement role based access control with
firebase and angular core our users are
going to have three different roles the
admin role can read and write anything
author role can read and edit but not
delete and the reader can only read data
since we can't actually edit the data on
the firebase object we need to create
our own custom user class will do this
by saving our own custom data to the
real-time database and in the user
object will have a roles object which
can either have an author reader or
admin attribute in the angular app I'm
going to use a typescript interface to
make sure that the user roles can't be
anything other than a reader author or
admin then I'm creating a custom user
class which is where we can define any
custom data we want to add to the user
object by default will pass the
constructor the firebase auth data and
use that to set an email photo URL and
then we'll set the reader value to true
by default so a new user will look like
this when they sign up in the database
so now we can build an off service to
actually log in and log out the user
we're going to use Google OAuth as the
login method so we import the
angularfire database as well as
angularfire
auth and our custom user class and we're
going to set our current user as a
behavior subject instead of the
angularfire
auth observable this will give us more
flexibility when we start working with
router guards inside the service
constructor we subscribe to the
angularfire auth off state observable
and we can add switch map which will
give us access to the auth user ID and
we can return the location in the
database that has this user data which
in this case is a user collection
followed by the user ID if the auth
object is undefined we just return a
null observable then we can call
subscribe and whatever we get back is
what will apply to that behavior subject
if the user is logged in this will be
the data from the database and if
they're not signed in it'll just be null
from here we'll add a method for the
user to sign in and sign out I'm just
going to go over this quickly because
it's the standard
or information you'll find in that
angularfire to documentation the only
difference is when the user logs in we
want to update the database with
whatever user information we want to
save there we can do this by creating a
new user object and then we'll check the
database to see if the data is already
defined and if it's not we'll go ahead
and update it with the default data from
this class so this code only run when we
have a brand new user signing up for the
first time with that out of the way we
can actually start building some
authorization rules our database has
some posts in it and we want to limit
access to who can create update and
delete these posts we can create a post
service to handle this logic so we'll
import the angularfire database our off
service as well as lodash we set a
variable user roles which is an array of
the roles that are actually assigned to
the current user we can define this
variable by subscribing to the user from
our off service and then we'll map the
roles down to an array of strings this
will make the code for our rules a
little less verbose the next step is to
create a couple functions to actually
get the data from the database and then
we can finally start writing some rules
related to this data first we're going
to write a helper function which is
going to see if there are any matches
between two arrays the reason is that
every rule is going to have an array of
allowed roles and we want to make sure
those roles match the actual user roles
this makes the authorization logic very
straightforward we just define an array
of the allowed roles and then we call
our helper function to see if there's a
match between those roles and the users
roles for example that can delete rule
only allows admin users so if an author
or reader user tries to perform this
action it'll return false so we can lock
down specific actions in the type script
directly by wrapping them in an if
statement in this case users can only
edit posts if the can edit rule returns
true if not it'll just say action
prevented and we can also perform the
same logic for deleting posts just using
the can delete rule if we go into the
app we can see we're currently logged in
with just the reader role so if we try
to edit or delete a post we'll see this
action prevented message in the console
but if we go into the database and give
this user the author role we should get
different results so now that we have
the author permission we can try to
delete a post but we'll still get the
same message because we're not
authorized to delete but we should have
access to edit the post so we click Edit
we go in here and we edit the data and
it should update in the database when we
go back we can confirm the post does
have the new text that we just entered
then we can go ahead and add the admin
role in the database and we should have
access to now delete the post when we
click delete this time we can see that
post is deleted and we don't get any
kind of error in the console it's also
important to point out that we could
just hide the delete button from the Dom
altogether and we can do this by using
ng F along with the can delete function
that we had defined in the post service
so just keep that in mind as an option
when you're securing data on the
front-end another option you have for
managing roles is with router guards so
here we're going to build a router guard
that only allows the author role to
access a certain route the logic is very
similar to what you just saw on the post
service we first subscribe to the
current user from our off service and
then we map the roles down to a boolean
which will return true if they have the
author roll and then false if they do
not then we can use the rxjs do operator
to run some arbitrary code which is
useful if you want to redirect the user
or raised like a toast message so when a
user tries to navigate to this route
angular will subscribe to this
observable and it will either return
true or false if it's false and they
won't be able to access that route so we
can apply it to individual routes by
going into our app router first make
sure the guard is in your providers
array and then on individual routes you
can add a can activate array and add
that guard to it if we try to navigate
to this route without the authored role
we'll see the route is blocked and we'll
also get this route prevented message in
the console and the last thing we're
going to look at is securing the
database on the backend we can use
firebase database rules to ensure our
data integrity even if our front-end
JavaScript code is hacked as you can see
here I've removed the can delete rule
from angular and our user only has the
reader role so they shouldn't be able to
delete post but we still get an error
from firebase because we've set some
back-end database rules the rules are
kind of hard to read so I recommend
going to angular firebase
on to get the full code but we'll go
through it really quickly here first we
set a rule for reading data so we make
sure that the user with that auth ID has
the reader attribute in the database and
we do this by traversing the database
with the route variable which is
provided by firebase for writing data
first we set the rule for the author so
we make sure that they're providing new
data which means they're not deleting
the post and then we traverse the
database again making sure that they
have the author role on their profile
otherwise for admin users we just need
to make sure that they have the admin
role on their profile and they can
create update or delete any data that
they want that's it for role based
access control of firebase if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you want the full code head over to
angular firebase com
and if you want access to exclusive
content as well as one on one project
consulting consider becoming an angular
firebase Pro thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you soon
[Music]